hi my name is jhanelle Hong and I'm a
senior at MIT studying brain and
cognitive sciences and computer science
and engineering and my project is about
enhancing human memory using augmented
reality I'm really interested in reverse
engineering the science of intelligence
to better understand abstract concepts
such as causal and moral reasoning and
intuitive psychology and common sense
understanding which are all things that
we use to better digest and process the
world around us here at the Genesis
group in csail we believe that human
intelligence is unique in our natural
capabilities to tell and understand
stories I think it's really interesting
to study the how memory and learning
play a key role in this very human
storytelling and so I based my research
off of various neuroscience studies at
MIT that elucidate how memory works in
patients of Alzheimer's disease so forms
of dementia take the ability to access
and retrieve memories away but we can
still encode and store them in the brain
just fine and so I studied the moment
where computers can help model and
augment our very natural learning
processes I do my research in the Media
Lab in the food interfaces group where
we're working on building a multi-modal
augmented reality system that digital
eyes is something called the memory
palace which actually dates back to
ancient Greek philosophy the memory
palace leverages imagination by
visualizing a space or a location that
you know very well and using mental
images or visuals and associating them
on particular points on the path you can
better consolidate these memories in
your brain
just by rewashing the path mentally or
physically as it turns out spatial
navigation and episodic memory both rely
on the same area of your brain the
hippocampus and so I use audio-visual
sensory cues to trigger neural firing in
the hippocampus to better consolidate
these memories through space
and the results have been really
promising over the past year I've been
carrying out a series of human
behavioral experiments and it shows that
the paradigm which I call memory lane
shows significant improvement in
retention in both short-term memory and
long-term memory by showing that sensory
cues can actually help us encode
memories in our brain better we show
that artificial intelligence can help us
both understand human cognition but also
unlock further innovations in assistive
mixed reality and so I hope that this
interface can serve as a good first step
in empowering people to overcome
learning barriers and memory impairments